[Applause]
milwaukee in possession as the fourth
quarter gets underway
middleton he thought it was fouled as he
came up short here's middleton
wide open and hits the throne
middleton now 21 on the evening
this is found money if you're nate
mcmillan he goes 6-9
245
middleton for three
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah he's struggling through that ankle
he's grimacing every time he's running
down the court
middleton oh he's filling it now
98 leads and middleton putting on a
show here in this fourth quarter
way off right glass that last shot by
nettleton
thought it was a two there's conaton to
the bucket then goes cross court
taco slips it out middleton for free
again
711 from downtown the pass here by
connorton to tucker middleton
getting it done well he's 12 of 22 with
32 points here in game three here's
middleton on the drive with the running
hook
middleton middleton has been on
fire guarded by mcdonough shoots over
and hits again coming up on a minute
remaining in this
fourth quarter five on the shot clock
middleton played by galinari
middleton with the jumper yes look at
this
they're straight one on one the olympian